In the orbit of WWE, all of the
personnel that comes through, everybody
that wants to touch, that wants to be
the biggest, the best or whatever.
Sometimes a lot of these things, you
know, they don't pan out the way that
some would want them to.
In your case, you know, you're talking
about how many years you have.
How many years do you have in there?
It's been a lot. I started in 2002.
And the beginning of it, what I found
like to be crazy was you coming in on
the you know, you kind of had to earn
your stripes, for lack of a better
word, right? Your comfort in that
space. It wasn't immediate with those
guys.
WWE, they run all the time.
But I think that's kind of where we
might have. And I'm thinking for you at
this point, but I think that's kind of
where we might have found common
ground. When was the first time you hit
the stage as a standup?
When was the first time you hit the
stage?
2000 and know 1998.
And that was in the space of Amateur
night and me just falling in love with
amateur night in competitions.
Small stage. But from 98 to 99 was
where it was just performing on things,
right? Like whether it was a stage,
whether it was a cabaret, whether it
was a lounge, we had to create our
environments. They weren't they weren't
all set up for comedy.
They weren't all like entertainment,
like environments.
But it's a nonstop grind.
Yeah, Yeah. And you're always on stage
and it's a different city every night,
and you're hustling and.
I went through the same thing.
Yeah. You know, it's the same thing.
And the business has changed so much
since I started. For the better.
Or the worse.
I think some. I think a whole lot
better. And I'm just again, I'm
thinking for you, I bet your comedy's
changed since 98.
Absolutely. Until now.
Absolutely. I bet you a lot of it's
changed.
I mean, the times the times have
changed, which in return have caused
comedy to change. Sure.
Right. So comedy has changed because we
had no choice but to change.
I hear you there, I hear you there.
In your side when you say it's changed
drastically, I feel like it's grown.
Right?
I feel like I think that's that's the
biggest thing that's changed.
It has grown exponentially.
Like, exponentially.
To the point where, you know, I always
preface the NBA and the ABA and the
70s, Major League Baseball in the in
the late 70s and 80s, pro football in
the 80s, like pro football.
Now it's a it's an operation.
The NBA now is an operation.
Major League Baseball is an operation.
WWE has kind of followed the same
trajectory where it is this massive,
globally reaching entertainment
juggernaut that can show up anywhere.
I've been to you know, I've been to
AT&T Stadium in Dallas and I performed
in Afghanistan. Yeah.
Like and everywhere in between.
And I think as as you have more success
and especially they cast a PG net the
program is PG but it also changed from
TV 14 to PG.
So and it's also a generational
product. Like I'll talk to older folks
and they'll be like, Oh, I grew up with
Hulk Hogan and Ricky Steamboat and Ric
Flair and Macho man Randy Savage.
And then there are people who'll be
like, The Attitude Era was the best
with Rock and Steve Austin and DX and
The Undertaker. And there are folks
that grew up watching me.
And then there's the current generation
that watches the current superstars
and, you know, comments and critiques
and appreciates that product.
So if it's not your generation, you
always romanticize about the
performers, the comics before.
I like Richard Pryor. I like George
Carlin. Yeah, I dig these comics
instead of what's what's up there now,
I don't I don't understand.
The same can be said for styles of
music. You know, I, I love hip hop
music, but I correlate to like 90s,
like boom bap style music and I just
don't understand a lot of the other
stuff. But it doesn't mean it's not
bad. It's just that I have like kind of
my, my sweet spot this, this stuff that
I romanticize about.
And as the company grows, it's trying
to it's trying to gain more of a
following. It's trying to gain more of
a fan base, a general fan base.
So you have to you have to act
accordingly, as the the great news is,
the I feel the the talent, the
performers are better taken care of.
They're more professional, they're more
understanding. They're not you're not
as wasteful. They're they're a lot
smarter. They're a lot healthier.
I mean, that's from seeing
the mistakes of others, right?
It's wisdom.